después de una breve persecución la
policía israelí confirmó el arresto de
un sospechoso que podría estar detrás
del ataque a un autobús este domingo por
la mañana se cree que este residente de
jerusalén éste abrió fuego contra el
autobús que transportaba pasajeros
israelíes mientras se dirigía a la
ciudad vieja el tiroteo ocurrió cuando
el bus estaba estacionado cerca del muro
de las lamentaciones un lugar sagrado
para los judíos al menos ocho personas
resultaron heridas en el ataque pero los
servicios de salud no reportaron
víctimas mortales
tres de ellos están en estado crítico y
el resto tienen heridas leves
con un bebé que está fuera de peligro
ellos fueron trasladados al hospital
para ser atendidos
el atentado sigue a una semana tensa de
luchas entre el ejército israelí y la
yihad islámica palestina 49 palestinos
perdieron la vida cuando varios aviones
israelíes realizaron una ofensiva en la
franja de gaza- para responder a un
ataque con cientos de cohetes de la
yihad islámica el episodio violento más
letal de la región en lo que va de año
terminó el pasado domingo con un alto el
fuego negociado por egipto